you grew up in Detroit and Ghana and
Ghana yeah like you spent time in both
places how did that work head well my
mother's from Ghana my dad's from
Detroit's we used to go back and forth I
mean like her first and second grade
like lived there full time in Ghana in
Ghana and like it's amazing it's
beautiful it's Africa you know but like
as a kid I didn't appreciate it at all
so that's like where's the McDonald's
yeah I where's the Ninja Turtles yeah
first thing I wanna do is like just get
home and like watching injure Turtles
and like just have that be my life that
there was not a lot of good TV shows
there's like very minimal very bit like
like there's two channels like watch
Captain Planet every here and there and
then like nothing so like I just want to
get back home and watch American
television okay
now you grew up on you or you were TV
addict when you're growing up TV addict
yeah so you claim that you know every
theme song of every TV should I do I
know every TV show theme song you can
quiz me actually facts of life you take
the good you take the bad you take the
rest in there you have a facts alive
family matters
the cookies on the newspaper thing who's
the boss it's a time for love my god no
open road
Randal wrap around the braids you know
my favorite was Charles in Charge also
new boy in the neighbor who lives
downstairs and it's understood yeah well
so it's got that line that I always
loved was Charles in charge of our days
in our own eyes Charles in charge of our
wrongs and our rights what is that mean
a lot to be in charge
what does Charles doing
[Applause]
you